The first ideas that eventually became
the Efficient Markets Hypothesis
were postulated by
Jules Regnault in 1863.
Eugene Fama carried those
ideas further in the 1960's,
and it became his PhD thesis.
Fama recently received a Nobel Prize,
so we know those ideas were good.
So what's the efficient
market hypothesis about?
We'll start by looking at some of
the assumptions that it makes.
Probably the most important assumption
is it that there are a large
numbers of investors interacting
in the market for profit.
So they have an incentive
to find opportunities
where the price of a stock is out of
line with what its true value is.
Because there are so many of these
investors operating simultaneously, any
time a little bit of information comes
out there, the price is going to move.
The next assumption is that new
information arrives randomly.
So it arrives at random times,
it arrives at random rates for
different stocks, but
it's constantly arriving and
investors are paying attention
to that information and
therefore the prices
are adjusting quickly.
Finally, the efficient
market hypothesis assumes
that the current price reflects
all available information.
In other words, all this information
that's trickling in is acted upon by
the investors, the price adjusts
quickly to that information, and
the current price reflects all of
the information about that stock.